if you can't put your values into your
vote then democracy is lost at sea
we have no moral compass and that's
exactly where we are right now people
are hungry for more choices but the
American political system excels at
suppressing the voices of opposition in
fact we are probably the only major
developed country that is limited to two
parties people are told over and over
don't vote your values vote your fears
but what we got was everything we were
afraid of all the reasons you were told
that you had to vote for the lesser evil
because you didn't want the massive
expanding Wars you didn't want the
meltdown of the climate you didn't want
the massive Wall Street bailouts you
didn't want the offshoring of our jobs
these are all things that were brought
to us signed sealed and delivered by a
Democratic White House with two
Democratic houses of Congress we have a
few things to learn about democracy in
our own country that we need to allow
opposition voices and opposition
political parties that's how we get to
real democracy in a true multiparty
democracy we'd have much easier access
and we would have inclusive debates so
you have many more points of view much
more diversity and it's much harder for
corporations to take control to buy out
the two parties and basically censor and
eliminate all other non corporate points
of view like living wages like the right
to a job like the right to free higher
education those are critical issues and
we need an open democracy to be able to
bring them into our political system and
forget the lesser evil stand up and
fight for the greater good like our
lives depend on it because they do